Araya is a group of islands in the
middle of the South Pacific Ocean 80
million years ago the chain of islands
broke away from the landmass they'll
eventually become New Zealand and
Australia it's made up of a series of
individual biomes including marine
histories and wetlands forests
snow-capped mountains and active
volcanoes as ghosts we spend the
majority of our time blowing it to
pieces in the fight to gain control of
scale tech headquarters however through
the game we come across a number of
relics stating as far back as 21,000 BC
and these give us numerous insights into
eras rich past
[Music]
you
the Ring of Fire refers to a chain of
volcanoes shaped like a horseshoe found
in the middle of the Pacific Ocean and
are the result of the plate tectonics
with a massive Pacific plate interacts
with the less dense plates around it
with 75% of the Earth's volcanoes
located along this chain and 90% of the
Earth's earthquakes occurring along its
path here at the edge of this Ring of
Fire
lyza our Islands let golem and duck wood
island and volcanic origins they are the
result of volcanoes that have surfaced
from the ocean floor thousands of years
ago Darkwood Island for example as a
last remnant of a monumental explosion
that occurred in 21,000 300 BC and is
thought to be of one of the largest
known volcanic explosions of all time
during the eruption ash and rock was
thrown into the atmosphere before the
volcano collapsed in on itself creating
Lake Catherine
[Music]
the earliest traces of human presence on
a row a date back to 500 BC unlike the
other people of the South Pacific
these first inhabitants came from the
East from Central or South America and
not from Polynesia these people had
navigational talents agriculture hunting
and fishing and technology based on
wooden stone after centuries on the
islands the civilization seems to have
just up and vanished sometime during the
16th century early evidence shows that
lives could have been because of
volcanic eruption in 1845 survivors of
the disappearance were found living deep
in the thick forests of dark wood Island
only a few families remained totalling a
number of around 100 with a language
that differed from those of Polynesia
they claimed their ancestors had come
from the east from an endless land and
that their people had abandoned the area
because of the anger of the earth in a
few generations these survivors were
integrated into the population of aroa
their language was lost as well as most
of their customs only a few families
kept bits of the old traditions such as
the ancestral names of their people the
kings of the forest this term can be
seen all over the islands represented in
the drawings of large felines the kings
of the forest civilization lived for
2,000 years on aroa mini ruins still
remain villages harbors forts cemeteries
and sanctuaries today they're commonly
referred to as the Ancients
1773 Captain Cook was on a second voyage
when he discovered Arella he found an
empty uninhabited land that noted that
it was covered in ruins and remains of a
civilization that once lived there the
Polynesians accompanying cook knew these
islands they called it Aurora
a land that was cursed in their eyes
according to them the people who lived
there came a long time ago from the
Rising Sun during the exploration
Captain Cook discovered the ruins of an
abandoned Spanish fortress the fort seem
to have been stormed and it's garrison
mess occurred so Westerners had in the
past already set foot on this land but
the discovery was never published
perhaps on purpose Captain Cook's
discovery of Aurora was followed by the
arrival of many adventurers in search of
a quick fortune
Europe's increasing demand for seal
skins brought a large number of hunters
to Aurora where at the time seal
colonies were plentiful traces of seal
hunting can still be found in the seal
islands and the channels areas
[Music]
the southern ocean is full of plankton
and krill meaning that the cold waters
south of Aurora shelter large population
of whales at the beginning of the 19th
century whaling ships prowled around
aroa and became a rose main source of
revenue ports and factories were built
along the western coast allowing the
hunting season to be extended extensive
hunting eventually led to the
disappearance of whales from this region
and with them the Whalers left a rower
near the end of the century abandoned
ports and factories may still be visited
on the wild coast whaler's bay and the
windy island regions in the 19th century
few Europeans were willing to make the
long uncertain journey to live in the
islands of Aurora in 1837 investors
created the Aurora company to boost the
population the private company covered
the travel costs for anyone who wished
to settle on these distant islands
settlers came in large numbers many of
them Scottish and chose the most fertile
regions of Arella to farm or breed sheep
[Music]
in 1860 a farmer discovered gold nuggets
will plow his fields the news spread
quickly throughout Aurora the gold rush
had begun settlers abandoned their plots
of land to pursue a career as
prospectors from neighboring New Zealand
Australia California and Europe
thousands of people came to seek their
fortune in Aurora by 1921 the gold
deposits had dried up and the
prospectors either returned home or to
their farms
December 1941 Japan had just attacked
the American base of Pearl Harbor the
Pacific Ocean became the new battlefield
of the Second World War as early as 1942
Japanese forces advanced through New
Guinea and the Solomon Islands
threatening Australia the United Kingdom
struggling in Europe was unable to help
it was the United States that took
responsibility for stopping the Japanese
advance towards the South Pacific the US
forces built many land sea and air bases
to support their efforts and erro
was chosen to host several of these
these bases were built in the Finn bulk
channels and sea islands provinces their
main role was to support the logistical
efforts of the Navy and aviation forces
no fighting took place on Aurora except
for a few air raids against airfields in
1945 the military population was around
21,000 and exceeded the civilian
population of 16,000 once the war was
over the number of sailors at these
bases was reduced to just a few hundred
by 1948 it was clear that the USA and
the USSR once fighting a common enemy in
world war ii had now become bitter
rivals their fight for global dominance
would continue for decades during this
period the Pacific Ocean became an
essential front of the Cold War the USSR
built a new war fleet aimed at competing
with the u.s. for control of the Seas as
the USSR increased its nuclear
capabilities US military bases were
established outside of the reach of the
Russian bombers already having the
infrastructure inherited from the Second
World War a role was chosen to house one
of these new major bases aimed at
blocking Russian expansion in the
decision
since the end of the Second World War a
rose population had fallen to less than
10,000 with the gold mines abandoned and
the whales and seals exterminated
agriculture was the only thing that
remained but the Pentagon had plans for
this area in order to combat espionage
it was preferable to settle on Islands
without civilians in 1949 talks with the
British government began and by 1953 the
British crown sold to the u.s. a
renewable 99 year lease for the
exclusive use of Varela for military
purposes following the British
government's Lisa varroa the Pentagon
ordered the eviction of the civilian
population this was accompanied by a
substantial compensation purchase of
land and payment of relocation costs to
either England or the United States most
of the remaining nine thousand
inhabitants on aroa accepted these
conditions abandoning the native islands
by the end of 1954 the last inhabitants
hiding in the jungle of the dark wood
island were captured and expelled over
the next five years the older World War
two bases were transformed into
state-of-the-art facilities most of the
villages were torn down to make way for
new settlements but there are a few
remnants of the old towns that can still
be found since 1965 the aurora islands
have become a giant US military base a
1953 agreement with the united kingdom
forbid the use or storage of nuclear
weapons on aroa
but they were secretly being kept in
underground shelters the Pentagon relied
on the absence of any civilian or
military surveillance to keep the
weapons a secret however spies managed
to infiltrate the base and information
was made public a crisis broke out
between the u.s. and the United Kingdom
the Aurora nuclear bomb crisis entered
in 1984 after the Pentagon removed the
bombs and promised not to store them
there in the future the departure of the
nuclear weapons was filmed in broad
but some continued to claim that not all
of them at lift aroa with the berlin
walls collapse in 1989 and the
dissolution of the USSR in 1991 the cold
war effectively ended in the absence of
an enemy the American government asked
the Pentagon to reduce its budget
accordingly one of the measures taken
was the closure of several bases
particularly those built outside of the
US so in 1996 the aroer base was
demilitarized and closed with the site's
equipment dismantled and shipped to the
US by the end of 1996 the aurora islands
were once again deserted but not for
long several former soldiers decided to
settle there illegally they would later
be known as the homesteaders though the
Pentagon still held a lease for the area
no one cared about these lost islands in
the South Pacific anymore so they were
put up for auction
and in 2008 JCL purchased surura to
become the hub for the technological
advancement of mankind and from here we
pretty much know how the story goes in
2009 construction of the new scale
technology headquarters begins on the
island and in 2020 drone production
begins there is a couple more relics
that we haven't managed to acquire so
there may be a date or tube missing or
maybe these are something meant to be
discovered later on but before I go any
further I must think a mate of mine for
helping me out with a lot of the
information I've discussed here I
certainly haven't had the time that I
wish that could have had to to find all
of the stuff in the game by now but
thanks to caves and has newly found
addiction to Ghost Recon break point he
was able to provide me with a lot of the
collectables and Intel if you guys can
do me a huge favor
he has just started streaming his new
addiction on Twitch he's been going for
maybe your week or two now including a
26 hour stream that crazy bastard as a
sign of thanks for me please PLEASE pop
over to his channel and say hi maybe
even check him a follow I'd really
appreciate it
a level link in the description he
really has done me a solid here and
probably would the next couple of videos
too so
come out you may even catch me partaking
in a stream from time to time I warn you
though here's a Kiwi too so you'll have
to deal with some more of that orchid
Kiwi accent anyway thank you very much
for watching and I'll catch you in the
next one
Cheers
you
[Music]